hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we're
supposed to go take the tram somewhere
and find a dead guy cuz that's perfectly
logical and reasonable I need more ammo
donor I'll get out of here med kits I
haven't been hit once I'm so awesome no
pick no pickle ah I'm gonna I'm gonna
kill this ah interface system is the
worst I swear oh how do I cycle through
there's got to be a way to cycle through
things on the floor Oh another bathroom
oh man eat me well fu man can't die here
not yet not like this not like this no
no not like this if you know what
reference I'm referencing well if you
know what I'm referencing kudos to you a
large med pack alright
again what what's whispering at me I
have no idea
it sounds like a computer system giving
out information but I can't quite make
it out
probably intentional elevator ma'am it's
sick of these elevators bring it on
bring it on bring it on
long boring elevator ride I'll bring it
on the store
hahaha okay that's why it was getting so
much money okay
store okay
what's that sound wait wait well what's
that what's that what's that something
what is that sounds like that door that
was slamming before Oh what fine okay
plasma cutter line gun pulse right like
that level to suit all more inventory
slots getting that gotta get back right
away gotta get that cuz my tiny
inventory is not cutting this guy's oh
yeah yeah step into the machine of
horrors
I trust it alright oh oh okay
it adds little itty bitty plates of
copper onto my armor and that somehow
makes it better okay then fine by me
I'm not questioning it okay um can't buy
anything else can't buy the guns I want
a gun I want another gun um what's this
wait oh I can sell stuff oh I can sell
something get a gun okay um uh stores
full hell's for stores medium amount of
health small amount okay I'm gonna
forego the small one yeah sure there are
stasis recharge things I saw in the
walls I'm guessing I don't need that
I'll keep going is that enough yeah I
can buy the
I'll take the assault rifle this way one
more that one sir I am Oh does it take
okay I've got an assault rifle with no
ammo so that was smart
I'm super smart I don't get four okay oh
yeah it comes with bullets yay oh oh oh
so much better than that pistol I had
okay bring it on I got a frickin assault
rifle now oh man I don't even know what
type of weapon that was before I think
it said plasma cutter so I don't know
shoots lasers it's the future everything
shoots lasers chapter one completed yeah
sure I'll save all right boink yes
overwrite gosh there's only four slots
of course I'm gonna be overriding at
some point okay
intensive care on the science medical
thing oh good all I get is a loading
screen
so the tram loads in between different
parts of the ship okay I'm liking the
game so far by the way the atmosphere is
really good oh wait you're live
hey come he's here wow he's really dead
be afraid of lady lady okay that's nice
what's this oh really this is a handful
of worms okay lady okay okay oh okay and
then you promptly die okay oh another
story okay almost I say a mode grab item
grab item like oh there's an item in
there going oh like that pick it up pick
it up I bought inventory space what
Wiseman I have inventories please pick
it up there we go
okay good surprised they had time to
wrap up the bodies I'm surprised you're
still alive lady or you were alive long
enough to just die in front of me his
story again
Hamdi huh mom okay I'm gonna sell medium
one I don't know are they
they sell ammo for the plasma cutter but
not for this new assault rifle so maybe
it wasn't such a good idea I figured
figured kippie that that is awesome
I mean it's bullets look at that boom
actually that's in my way
oh don't get stuck oh damn get out of
here oh god you're slow here shoot yeah
yeah on a body bag Sam
gimme okay there we get out of here
oh-ho that is a lot of worms oh that is
a lot of worms I meant to shoot that man
look at that oh that is gross
why are there worms on a spaceship oh
okay
flame through lame thrower I want that I
don't think I have enough money for
right now but I want it okay this is
good oh hi we were attacked Kendra's
gone one may she was ass isn't dead
can't believe I lost her way to go token
black guy we can still do this get me
the captain's records and we'll find
Nicole Nicole looks like the barricade
the door to the emergency ring yeah oh
that's nice to get to the moisture get
some thermite from medical storage and a
shock pad from zero-g therapy should be
down the corridor whatever you say man
is useless on all the static whatever
you say man okay okay but I get look
I don't know what was that MF repulse
trifle album is that my weapon did it
get more no okay another store I just
went to a store I don't need another one
okay which way I'm going
ah okay research would you do it Oh
bring it on so ready there we go
huh hey don't be moving all weapons have
an alternate I'm okay
second Aries fire space oh oh Sh
ha I just wasted so much it darn it darn
it okay that was was ammo I don't trust
you guy oh I can snap off your limbs too
good
okay I'm actually going to switch weapon
because I'm not going to waste ammo on
my most powerful weapon right see I knew
it I knew it their stasis returns things
everywhere
see it yeah all right
okay
Oh brightly lit that's not gonna last
for long what Oh
what is that what is thumping oh it's
just the door okay okay that's locked
hello oh of course of course
okay of course okay second hey hey hey
hey hey hey find the balls
let go oh yeah it out of here nope nope
gone pedal point point
oh so pro oh so pro yep all done don't
trust you
hey trust you
nope I hear something something Jimmy
order whoa
what what what oh not even a little
threat coming up blew your head off
there you go okay it seemed to flail
around a lot when I blow their head off
maybe they can it's probably strategy
maybe they can like accidentally hit the
other guys when they're flailing around
oh I'm so smart that's so it all it's so
it okay so if there's a bunch of them
blow one of their heads off and they'll
kill the other oh so smart so smart
oh hey slam ha ha ha
one shot yeah hey whoa hey whoa whoa
whoa hey hi Hey reload reload reload
right now mouse mouse no crime out on me
now mouse mouse mouse now gimme gimme
gimme gimme
get dead get dead please get dead please
die oh okay
my mouse is apparently dying it's not
Wireless it's just old apparently oh oh
oh you are ugly you're so ugly and you
got worms coming out of you
oh I don't trust any of you oh man
another stasis module okay oh you don't
look so good Isaac you don't look so
good
whoo okay okay um I'm gonna go find
another Mouse so that never happens ever
again it's very unfortunate because this
is a little very nice Mouse it's the
Logitech g9x
very very nice now Mouse but I got it
like two years ago so and it's gone
through through them abuse as you could
tell us me slamming it down on the
mousepad there but anyway whoo hope you
enjoyed that thank you guys so much for
watching I always appreciate enter
everyone in my viewers so thank you
again and I will see you in the next
part
bye bye